so anti-muslim I run a sales recruitment
agency infinity side experience in space
he's awesome
they're really really good so many
like-minded people everybody turning out
from the profession for somebody fairly
new to recruitment like me it was great
to be able to get perspective from
people that I've been in the industry
for a long time and also to meet weird
people that have not been in this
interest in the industry for that long
either and yeah just a really good
atmosphere
well obviously the network in the
network has been great just to get a
feel for what different people are doing
how they're working with each other in
industry and how they're really building
up as a profession the people that
you're gonna meet put the stories that
you're gonna hear they're all things
that people have experienced that are
going to help you to be able to become a
better recruiter whichever aspects of
recruitment that you're looking for
advice on you can get it from this
podcast and also just the feeling of
knowing that there's people that have
been in that position that have been
through what you're going through that
can help you to get to where you want to
get to
you